[Music]
so it's interesting because i always
hear from like in the red pill they tell
guys if she doesn't sleep with you
within three dates to like move on
because she's not genuinely attracted to
you
i don't i don't i don't i don't agree
with that i think it's i have a rules i
tell guys who are coach if she doesn't
kiss you within the first three dates
for sure move on
um
but i would say the biggest thing is
having sexual progression
so if let's say she doesn't kiss you on
the first date but then actually kisses
you in the second date but let's say
it's not a full-out kiss it's like a
peck on the lips or whatever fine let's
say the third date she kisses you with
some tongues there's a better hands
going somewhere there's sexual
progression that's good
and in fact if i was being honest if i
was dating a girl i'm going to take that
girl more seriously than the girl who
has sex with me on the first date
whereas if it's a girl if you don't get
anything for the three dates fax move on
she's not into you she doesn't have
general desire if she doesn't sleep with
you no maybe she's just a woman who's
worthy of being a wife when do you okay
when would you tell a guy
to like like to move on if she
like how long would you say look at she
hasn't slept with you within that long
you gotta go boy
i had this situation recently um
if she hasn't slept yeah yeah
have they done anything or no
have they done have they done nothing
nothing past making out
nothing past making out yeah
they say okay let's say you're going on
an average one day a week
right after five weeks you haven't you
haven't gone past kissing after five
weeks nah bounce bro
god i'm out because it's interesting
because i'll hear men like i kind of
understand both sides a little bit yeah
yeah what i mean what would you say
would you tell men
like men
gosh it's hard because
god it depends on the girl you're like
if it was me i didn't kiss it till the
sixth month
i've got six no i would tell them
six months
no it's just more like like okay i know
girls that'll make guys hold out because
they don't view them in that way
i think guys don't view them or she
doesn't view it like like she'll sleep
with one guy right away but she'll make
another guy wait because she doesn't
view the one guy in that way
like she's more in that way she's more
attracted to the guy that she slept with
straight away yeah
i think she's more physically attracted
yeah but i don't think that's the one
who she values more
because women who i think women who
you tell me what you think i think women
if they're if a guy
doesn't have a lot of
qualities that's good for long term so
let's say
stable whatever but he's
really attractive she'll sleep with him
because she's like oh well whatever
but if he does have a lot of great
qualities long term and she's attracted
to him
if she's clever she won't sleep with him
straight away
because she knows that probably is going
to eliminate her as long term in his
eyes
i would say sometimes
sometimes but it kind of it kind of goes
bad i hate these terms i hate to do it
but i think
a lot of times the girls like views the
one guy is more beta
i think i think i think there's like
there's like um a level of attraction
where a girl will have and i just think
like
i don't that's the problem is it's
really hard to distinguish and it really
depends on the girl
yeah you don't do you know what i'm
saying yeah because i think i've had it
like i i've had it where sounds so bad i
don't know
i'll just be honest i've had it where
like really attractive girls
have been like
some have like just slept with these
straight away
and then they've been girls who
arguably a lot of guys she's attractive
not as attractive but because she really
didn't want to [ __ ] her up she
she didn't sleep with me straight away
because she was like i don't want to
lose the chance of having this guy
as a serious term i don't know that
might be what she told you maybe what i
mean
i'll be honest man it happened
well she definitely asked me to be her
boyfriend or whatever yeah oh my god
how'd that go for her
uh one of two of them i said no one of
them
we were together for two oh yeah yeah
okay
in relation to like the whole like alpha
beta thing it's so funny because
i'm like oh would i rather
sleep with like an alpha on the first
date because i'm like
oh i'm really attracted to you and like
you make me feel a certain way
or
would i rather sleep with a beta because
i'm like well i don't see any longevity
or any like worth or value in you so i
actually really can't decide in i think
you do see value in the beta just not
the same as the alpha oh yeah yeah yeah
so no because you know the alpha's not
gonna stick around but the beta probably
would yeah so that's that was like yeah
to say no was like the wrong kind of
term but it's like actually like
yeah and my dating life is very that's
i'm very much like [ __ ] there really
isn't a one-size-fits-all because
i've been giving my time and attention
to men that maybe don't really respect
me and then i went on a date with a man
that really did respect me and i was
like right
i do recognize that i really want to
sleep with you more than anyone else but
i don't want to sleep with you but then
all my past relationships
i
slept with them on the first date and
they still like yeah i'm gonna like
commit to you and so it's like ah it's
yeah can i be honest why i think that
might have been and that's no disrespect
to them i don't know
um and i'm only saying this because
you said that in your previous
relationships that your friends were
like they're they were punching like you
out their league
there are a lot of guys who are in
relationships
because that is their only access to
regular sexual
intimacy
um
and they'll commit to the first girl
that comes along not saying that's not
not saying that was the case or rather
not that they'll commit to the first
girl that comes along but they are more
like they have more of an incentive to
commit to a girl who gives them that
access if that is something that they
don't get on a regular basis does that
make sense yeah no
i'll actually agree with that because i
had one boyfriend that's it the one who
was very he was very
he'd slept with a lot of women he was
very in demand but then he actually was
a very toxic awful human being and
treating me really badly so i'm like in
my mind when you were talking i was like
oh he's the exception because he got a
lot of attention but then i'm like oh
but then it's kind of like
it almost enabled him to treat me really
badly and so this is i'm a very big um
point in my life where i've i've got a
self-imposed deadline of april where i'm
gonna stop dating i'm gonna stop
if anything
i don't feel like i'm disrespecting
myself by being casual but i'm now like
i've done that i've had fun i'm not
really benefiting and i don't feel like
men are taking me seriously because i'm
casual and not that i want them to you
know everyone who's like oh you're not
my girlfriend i'm like that's cool i
don't want to be your girlfriend but now
i'm like oh actually
i think if anything oh this sounds awful
because i hate to
be like
low caliber but i'm like oh no like i
know what i bring to the table and i
actually know that that's it casual
aside body count aside i know that i'm
actually quite a high caliber and i
bring a lot to the table but i do have
to be real and be like
maybe my behavior doesn't show men that
and i'm like you know what come april
i'm entering my hot villain era i'm
gonna make all the men who did me and
that because that's what happens is men
that cheated on me or did me wrong or
didn't want to commit to me
they all come back around at some point
and they all drop in my dm so i'm like
this is like really interesting sex
some
probably but i don't sleep with them but
they they still go so my really really
toxic ex we broke up three years ago
he's the one that told me that he had
cancer i dropped my job my home my
friends i i literally gave up i got
really unwell because he was
awfully cheating the whole time i really
allowed him to treat me really badly and
i'm like you cheated on me you didn't
respect me you ended things with me
why are you still messaging me three
years later when i know you've got a
yell but he knows as well that i'm sex
yeah sex and i'm like wow i think i
think from the relationship that it
sounds like you've had
he
believes that he can still
control you
he does that so you
you answer though don't you
oh you don't no so well
so i posted a picture on my instagram of
me in like some lingerie it looked good
i was thirst trapping i was seeking
attention no shame in this game and he
went
oh that's my saturday sorted as in i'm
gonna masturbate over you and i was like
you you've got a girl this is not
appropriate and then he went i'd love to
see more pictures and i went yeah there
are more but they're not for you and he
was like oh okay and i was like to be
fair yeah i should just ignore it i
should just and so every time i reply i
am giving him a bit of power and i am
yeah